it was last thursday night that lamar
jackson was questionable for the game
against the jets with a quad injury he
played he played very well the good news
for the ravens yesterday his name was
not anywhere on the wednesday report
which means he is healed and he is good
to go and the number one seed is on the
line chris when the ravens go to
cleveland this week the browns one of
the only teams that have beaten somehow
how how
do you lose yeah and well the match-up's
coming again because it's ravens at
browns and yesterday lamar jackson said
as the ravens close in on the potential
number one seed in the afc he's not
listening to the hype here he is
i try to block out all the noise you
know whether it's positive or negative i
don't try to get caught up into it you
know just like i did and at the
beginning of the season you know um
people hopping on our bandwagon now you
know but we all knew what we had you
know with the store with uh what he said
with ourselves um in the building but
like i said i block it out i play ball
that's all i'm here for
hey it's a good thing that people are
hopping on the bandwagon lamar you can't
find his jersey anywhere he's got his
own clothing line john harbaugh was
wearing one of the hoodies yesterday
that lamar jackson's selling this is it
strike while the irons hot baby make
some money and they are welcome those
folks on the bandwagon it is on of
unlimited size and i can't remember a
time even when the ravens were super
bowl champions i can't remember a time
where they generated this kind of
excitement because defense doesn't
generate this kind of excitement your
offense does that's what it is it's the
first time really in the ravens history
that offense is driving you know the
conversation even though the defense is
still great but this is a scary matchup
for the baltimore ravens you know it is
and the reason the cleveland browns beat
them the first time hey baltimore wants
to play aggressive on defense right mike
we know that we watch it every week you
know their dbs are up in your face as
far as wide receivers they got guys that
cloud crowd the line of scrimmage hey
that's great but if nick chubb breaks
one tackle like we saw in the first
matchup it's zoom it's 50 yards to the
house touchdown if odell beckham jr
jarvis landry get off of that jam press
coverage it's zoom it's a big play i
mean so that's where it's a little scary
cleveland has the assets on the
offensive side of the ball to stress the
ravens scheme and players a little bit
that way let alone steve wilkes is a
pretty good defensive coach and he
understands run fits i know their
defense is not dominant this year and
all that but uh you know i i give them a
fighting chance here with nothing to
play for this is scary they're going to
get off on like screwing up baltimore's
plans if they can pull off a victory
here
yeah i agree with you completely and
freddie kitchen thinks he's still
coaching for his job right i mean
there's a lot of things that are out
play to motivate the browns
20 years later 24 years later there's
still some people in cleveland that are
salty about the fact that the browns
became the ravens and all the success
they've had they think those are super
bowls they should have won in cleveland
so there's some animosity there to the
extent they can screw things up they're
going to be happy to do it but uh you
know i just i feel like the ravens are a
much different team than they were but
yeah they are you're right you're right
i agree they just they yeah they've got
they've just got a lot they ooze
confidence i think they were trying to
figure out still who they were yeah they
got slapped in the face in kansas city
the week before and maybe they just
weren't ready for the browns i don't
know what it was and i don't i can't
process it i can't comprehend it and i
think that john harbaugh and company
will know that uh this is an opportunity
to wash that bad taste out of their
mouth conclusively and convincingly and
i you know we're gonna do the mega pix
podcast later today where we make our
selections for all games but i just
can't imagine the ravens having a hard
time with the browns but i wouldn't have
imagined it in week four either yeah no
i wouldn't have either it is dangerous i
mean of course i'm leaning towards the
ravens too you're right they're a
different team now marcus peters that
trades helped their defense out you know
they figured out exactly how they want
to attack on the offensive side of the
ball and lamar the lamar jackson factor
is real it doesn't matter you know it's
great but every week we see teams go
talk about lamar jackson talk about
lamar jackson it's all fine and dandy
until you got to tackle lamar jackson
and that's the other thing you see too
you see guys in the right position
prepared to make the tackle and
everything like that and then he breaks
their ankles and turns the corner for 30
yards so you see that a few times every
week because it's impossible to prepare
for the talent and skill set that lamar
brings to the table
you know a question that that needs to
come up every week as teams get ready to
play the ravens and lamar jackson is
who's running the scout team
offense and who's playing the role of
lamar jackson and even then i don't know
that there's anybody out there who can
simulate lamar jackson you can pretend
to you can maybe come within shouting
distance but your defense still isn't
going to be ready for lamar jackson no
matter what
you do to prepare for lamar jackson yeah
no definitely not i mean you might get
guys out there who can run as fast as he
can straight away but what we've seen is
he's got incredible body language and
you know the ability to make people miss
an incredible feat i mean he's got as
good as feet as any receiver running
back in the sport to make people miss in
space and that's why he's the mvp of the
league right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports